objectif améliorer la circulation sur
l'un des axes les plus bouchés du
département le chantier de la RD30 est
rentré dans une nouvelle phase et
notamment sur le secteur 1 celui des
gaâtines la plupart des travaux sont
désormais terminés les derniers
aménagements les plus compliqués ont
débuté eu durant l'été mise en service
prévu début
2017 ce secteur avant était un secteur
fortement
encombré la RD30 où il y a il y avait un
flux important de gens qui ce qu'on
appelle traversant qui passe qui ne font
que passer par la RD30 rencontrer sur
trois endroits le flux local donc ça a
amené d'énormes conflits et des bouchons
importants les travaux avancent
également sur les secteurs 2 et 3 le
futur rond-point du petit saintclou
situé au nord du chantier sera ainsi
mise en service progressivement à partir
de la fin de l'année à terme l'objectif
c'est de séparer les flux de transit
avec les flux locaux pour pour cela en
fait on réalise la dénivélation
c'est-à-dire que la RD30 passera sous le
futur gératoire afin de séparer les deux
trafics les travaux de la RD30 prévoi
également l'installation de protection
acoustique ou la création d'une voie
verte coût du projet un peu plus de 78
million d'euros dont 45 à la charge du
département